time is funny but not haha funny
peculiar like how many times in the past
six months have you thought to yourself
something like
wait where did the time go what day is
it again
nine years ago i was having some of the
same frustrations i was super busy as we
all like to say
but i was beginning to feel like i only
lived in yesterday
or in between alerts i wanted more time
to be present
you know to live in the moment even
though i had no idea how to do that
so what is time's problem i felt
uniquely qualified to figure that out
because i had become an expert at
exploring time as a video editor
speeding time up slowing time down
making time more valuable
and then i asked the question that
changed my life how can we live in the
moment
when the moment changes every second
the problem with time is that there
isn't enough of it
to get to know time better we're going
to need
a longer now instead of making time as a
filmmaker i began to develop a series of
analog
timepieces that could help myself and
others enrich
our awareness of time because there is
an uncharted territory within us
all and that is your individual
temporal bandwidth how long
is your now if we only see time as a
man-made contraption
our temporal bandwidth remains thin
forging a tenuous and fragmented
experience
of life isn't this one of the gifts of
the 10 000 year clock
besides bringing us all together here
now it stretches our collective temporal
bandwidth
to a beacon ten thousand years ahead and
that perspective is vital
because it shows us where we are now
where we are now
is that we live in the long-term effects
of short-term thinking
how do we get to the part where we live
in the long-term effects of long-term
thinking
well there has never been a better time
than right now
to find out i believe that it is
possible for us
to change the times we live in all we
have to do
is change the time we live in
so that we can say with certainty that
that was then
and this is now the present
you are looking at the trio of
timepieces collectively known as the
present
that i have created to solve the problem
of not having more time
in this life
by tuning our awareness to the perennial
cycles of the day the moon
and the year we can collectively
rediscover the original nature of time
and a longer now
the present day is inspired by the view
of time
on earth from the window of an airplane
this 24-hour numberless clock guides you
through a spacious meditation on dawn
noon
dusk and night a generous companion to
the relentless precision
of industrial time inspired by the
design challenge of modernizing the
ancient yin-yang symbol
the present moon guides you through a
29.5 days
span of shadow and light that is the
lunar cycle
the full moon at the top and the empty
moon at the bottom
inspired by the breathtaking suchness of
being alive
on earth the present year spans 365 days
gradually upgrading your depth awareness
of time
by presenting a holistic point of view
on the nature of change itself
the president invites us to be the first
generation in this century
to consciously enrich our temporal
bandwidth
and turn the page on how we read the
story
of time
story of time as we know it is still
stuck in the industrial era
but hey look at where we get to go
together we have
the chance right now to co-create a new
understanding of time that guides our
thinking and behavior
into greater harmony with nature
don't worry industrial time isn't going
anywhere it's an incredibly useful tool
to help us be on time we don't want to
lose that
but we also don't want to focus so
closely on it that we never learn what
it's like
to be in time you see
me and thousands of other people in 42
countries
have been living with the present for
many years now and we know
that it does what we hoped it would do
the present
gives time space for a longer now
advancing our ability to read time while
expanding our temporal bandwidth to make
room for the big ideas
and the long-term solutions to all of
the current problems
that we've invented with short-term
thinking
as long as we rely solely on
short-term devices to tell the story of
time
we banish ourselves from the subtleties
of the natural world
and unconsciously limit the boundaries
of the human experience
with the present it no longer has to be
that way